let me tell you something I'm about to
kiss your ass a little bit here cool all
right all right you're about to get your
ass kissed well I got no pimples today
we used to be the ones who were doing
Jim a favor because Jim's movie you
didn't have an excited you weren't you
and Earth Girls Are Easy and some stuff
like that that's none of your damn
business
no Jim was like not like a lead role or
anything no but I'm saying he would do
some movies once in a while but nothing
big had broken Jim Carrey always did a
good job on In Living Color he's been
doing a good job for a long time but to
make that solid performer
at the end of the show they'd always
have people get up and dance and Jim is
obviously quite good at that in the
beginning you'd see Jim wouldn't really
dance that much and then all of a sudden
it used to be a circle thing where each
one would get out and do a little thing
thank you yeah so then you do some goofy
little dance something comical yeah
right not real dancing of course so you
know Jim goes ahead and they hire him
for something called Ace Ventura Pet
Detective which must have been the worst
script ever written on the planet Earth
now people realize if he could take a
bad movie and make it good this guy's
big now they're even he kept sending
messages give it a chance yeah give it a
chance
please just go see it so now put a
baseball cap that's right no what's
going to happen in your career now is
you are going to get movies oh he's
gotten them but you're going to get not
only comedies you're a good serious
actor I could see it in you yeah I mean
seriously if you went into into a movie
called Ace Ventura Pet Detective yeah
and you were like doing the stuff I was
doing in that movie would you would you
be expecting while you're doing that
movie that that it was going to be huge
no absolutely yeah and then that
happened it was basically you know maybe
a few people will see this or it'll
destroy my career right but uh you know
kind of when you're feeling a lot of
pressure now is that what you're saying
yeah man no you're not gonna crack or
anything are you
foreign